so the goal of this video is to try to
compare these two quantities i have 0.17
and i have 0.2 and i want to figure out
which of these two is larger or maybe
they're equal and i encourage you to
pause the video to try to figure that
out
well one way to do it is to try to
visualize these and so each of these
large squares you can view as a whole
and this one on the left i have it split
into 100 smaller sections because you
notice we have 10 rows and each row has
10 squares so we have 100 squares here
so each of these squares represents a
hundredth of the whole
and so this number up here 0.17 we could
do that as 17 hundredths so let's color
in 17 hundredths so seventeen hundredths
is going to be
so that's one hundredth two
three four five six
seven eight nine
ten hundredths and notice ten hundredths
i filled in one out of the ten rows so
this is the same thing as one tenth so
that's ten hundredths
eleven hundredths twelve hundreds
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
seventeen
so one way to visualize 0.17 which is 17
hundredths is the fraction of this hole
that is filled in in magenta now what
about 0.2 well 0.2 is the same thing as
2 tenths and so we could take our whole
and divide it into tenths divided into
10 equal equal sections which we've done
here notice each of these sections is
equal to 10 hundredths and that makes
sense 1 10 is equal to 10 hundredths but
let's fill in two of them now because
we're dealing with two tenths
so let's fill in two of them so we have
one-tenth
and two-tenths
so which of these
which of these is larger
well we see we're filling in more of the
whole we're doing two tenths then we're
doing when we're doing 17 hundredths and
that makes sense because two-tenths is
the same thing
two-tenths is the same thing another way
of thinking two-tenths is you could
write it as
twenty hundredths twenty hundredths is
greater than seventeen hundreds to get
to twenty hundredths you would have to
fill in these three as well notice when
you fill out those three you're filling
out the same fraction of your whole
so which one's larger well two tenses
and how do we write that down
well when we write an inequality we want
to open to the larger number so you want
to open to that one so we have 0.17 or
17 hundredths
is less than two tenths
now another way that we could have
tackled this even without kind of having
to draw all of this
is we could have just gone to the
largest place value so if you go to the
if you go went to the ones place you've
got okay we have zero ones and we have
zero ones here all right so that doesn't
help us then you go to the next largest
so then you go to the tenths place here
you have one tenth here you have two
tenths so immediately without even
looking at what comes after this this
could be
0.17358 it could keep going but the
bottom line is you have more tenths here
than you have tents here which tells you
that this one over here is going
this one is going to be larger so the
general thing is look at the largest
place value
if one of one of the numbers has a
larger digit in the largest place value
is going to be larger if they're equal
go to the next larger place value and
you could keep going like that but
another way to think about it is just to
visualize it just like we did over here